by the way with that story with uh fox
news story being brilliant you saw
wallace went to cnn right on their app
and then howard stern says who gives a
no one no one watches cnn's apps
anyway so what are you going on there
for
uh and then uh what's it called brian
williams uh uh uh resigned he left yes
bye-bye yeah so he leaves wallace to cnn
what do you think about what's going on
here
what did that negotiation sound like
with wallace was it kind of like well
cnn you ain't looking too good i think
it's a good time you hire a conservative
i'm a good guy to hire because i'm
pretty safe but here's what i want from
you if you give me these things i'll
come if you don't i'm not coming and
sienna needed that victory to say we got
somebody from fox you think that's the
play no i don't know because if you take
a look chris wallace he was not
expensive brian williams was very
expensive what was fox payne chris
wallace
pox
well brian williams was like at four and
a half a year and they were stuck with
him because it was this long-term
contract and then he had the
you know i was being chased by
helicopters with gunfire and everything
like this and the lies that he told
about all that yeah i think he was
making more than four now seven million
wallace was paying paid seven million
that does that does not wow that's
insane they're telling you right now he
made seven million dollars
15 20. i mean when he was when he was
doing nightly news he was making 50
years
you know but but you're right patrick
there's a lot of shuffling going on
chris wallace right now chris wallace
also has the name mike wallace you know
he's got the lineage there so there's 10
million
chris wallace is a democrat and a lot of
fox news watchers were getting
irritated with him
just like they were shepard smith i like
i thought he was a fantastic job
there's a very very very very very
measure that he did with bill clinton
bill clinton came out of his shoes and
was leaning into his face right into his
grill
remember when he moderated the debate
and everybody was all over chris wallace
because he wasn't hard enough on the
democrats you could kind of see that you
know he really did and after 18 years
with fox news you probably want to go
somewhere else and have a little bit
different perspective spin that you can
put on stories and i think it's it's not
just a show it's it's cnn digital right
so it's going to be a different type of
format he probably just needed a
challenge in his career yeah but it's
just like kidding me katie who bill
o'reilly has faded into the
uh oblivion yeah yeah uh-uh and katie
but
different circumstances he was ousted
because of sexual harassment true and
nobody else hired him you know he's
gonna be front and center at cnn be the
face of their digital
i bet they paid them 12. what do you
think brian's going to be doing next
brian williams i couldn't find cnn
digital if you i can't even google cnn
digital i don't think there's any i
don't think there's any market for brian
williams whatsoever i don't think he'll
get a job i don't think he'll get a high
level network job no way and i don't see
him being savvy enough to go the glenn
beck route or anything like that and he
doesn't have any particular views that
you buy into i never bought brian
williams in general because he does not
have a magnetic position there's not a
magnetic position their way there always
was for rush there always was for back
there always was for hannah you know
what i'm saying they have that center
that's that the cult personality
i think you have to have enemies to be
cult-like brian williams wasn't
necessarily a guy that had too many
enemies he'll be like matt lauer just
fade away in the hamptons what the
warning immediate discovery deal means
for cnn and jeff sucker what am i
looking at cnn is about to be acquired
by warner media and their ratings are
obviously tanking so you have to wonder
between chris wallace chris cuomo etc
what are they trying to do are they
trying to shake things up they're trying
to get more moderate to bring their
ratings up like they have to do
something they're a syncing jeff zucker
has no clout in the deal have you
noticed that
going through it he's got no position
coming out of the deal discovery's going
to run the thing a good point you make
tyler there so so what what are you
saying are you saying um
are you saying like they have to become
moderate because no one wants nobody
wants to buy cnn type of a business i
don't i don't think they have to become
moderate per se but they have to move
away from the far left almost
propagandist brainwashing but get away
from the brian stelters and and and that
kind of stuff which is where a chris
wallace sort of moderate can come in and
change things up i think jeff zucker
will be possibly gone after this like
you look at what they did after bringing
back jeffrey toobin yeah i mean it's
they they've just completely shot
themselves in the foot and they have to
do something daniel
where do you get your news from what do
you watch
i don't i don't listen to anything i
watch bloomberg you watch bloomberg but
because it's bloomberg tv it's got like
information i got you that's a different
story though yeah yeah that's a
different story
the 35 000 a year type of deal you talk
about that you talk about the membership
of bloomberg no i mean i mean the
television station bloomberg tv because
it's got all the information on it i got
you i mean but you don't listen to you
don't watch or listen to anybody
is there anybody that you would say i
kind of like hearing this person's
perspective or two
i think um remember my second masters is
in journalism so i totally believe in
the the idea of fair and balanced so i
think i think bret baer is a is a good
is a good journalist i'll i'll watch him
on the evening news you know if
you know if i had to watch the evening
news but i don't i watch bloomberg asia
tom how about yourself uh in the morning
it's cnbc it's walking the street
morning bell i think and i like the way
that they put new stories in and they
kind of just give you a like a
middle-of-the-road cover glitzy it's all
that's all entertainment i just want
them
no but then i go to then i go bounce
back and forth between fox business and
cnn business and you know i'll scan you
know a bunch of uh news grabs like um
business insider i'll scan that but um i
don't have one guy that that is my go-to
you know i used to be such a news junkie
i worked in news i was an anchor for 15
years i don't watch any news i do not
sit down and watch a local newscast or a
national newscast but i can't local news
is scary yeah i consume information all
day but there's a lot of i just i forced
myself to get a balance and you know
what
cnn is unwatchable but cnn business is
is a very tolerable site to read i have
no problem reading cnn business i'm
regularly i like reading the new york
post you know i like the daily mail
sometimes but you you always get bought
you get sucked into the agenda that they
all have and they all have some sort of
agenda so i just tell everybody just to
you know don't go deep on watching news
i mean it will ruin your life the
financial times is becoming woke i mean
it's really difficult right now to to
not it's really difficult to find just
unvarnished information
that's not in some way tainted by the
editorial team you can't even
i've got friends who work inside the
wall street journal who work inside the
financial times well here's one great
example pat did you hear about this
story so sunday night football michelle
tafoya is the sideline reporter right so
she hasn't been on the games for the
last three or four weeks yep i saw that
okay so now they just announced that
she's not coming back this is going to
be her last year and nbc said that she
wasn't working the previous few weeks
because it was a bye week for her which
makes zero sense all right why would you
have your star sideline reporter take a
week off you know when the nfl season
only goes 17 games so what happened
about a month ago is she was on the view
and she sat in the conservative chair
okay so for one day she was on the view
and she said on the view that day that
she thought covid was more like flu
right she downplayed the significance of
covid and since then she's been
whitewashed she's been banished she
hasn't been on the sidelines and now
she's done and pretty much that's why
people are saying it's happening she
will have a job within 30 days if she
wanted to michelle tafoya is a beast
she's not going to have a hard time
finding a job she's smart and she's
multi-sport and she doesn't need the
producer in her ear she reads the games
really well yeah yeah she's not gonna
have look look if she wants to look how
quickly she'll end the job michelle if
you're listening or if anybody knows
michelle
reach out to valuetainment
we would actually offer a job too
because she's a monster exactly she
loved the way she uh her salary drove
down to earnings if only we had someone
on staff that was already supported okay
check this out so
uh uh what her salary is 1.96 million no
net worth is 1.96 her salary is 27 000 a
month that's what her salary is and i'm
serious it's what's showing right now 27
000 a month
abtc.ng so someone's going to pick her
up so she gets six grand a game
here's uh 200 000 a year is two hundred
thousand dollars here's what our salary
is remember
espn doesn't pay as well as people think
they right right people think espn pays
very well nfl refs make more than that
they make way more than that
and and michelle is
got a lot of clout she's got a lot of
credibility yeah she's been around a
long time she's she's like 57. you hit
news i like how michael she's awesome
she's she hasn't taken anything yet
she's multi-sport she's covered in mba
that's what you're saying on the floor
yeah
in terms of changing
oh she also slammed nbc's michelle okay
let me pull this one up because you just
brought it up
long time nbc sports sideline reporter
michelle tuffos changing roles after
criticizing colin kaepernick's netflix
series for liking the nfl to slavery
during november
episode of the view uh and yeah i
remember this uh back and forth with
what she said no one uh pressures them
so this was again on the view no one
pressures them she told view co-host
sunny hostin austin on november 3
episode prompting criticism on social
media they're not forced to go into the
nfl tafoyo who has uh been on the nfl
sidelines et cetera certainly loves
whatever yeah i mean if you haven't seen
it you gotta watch it she's a beast she
stood her ground so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]